as coronavirus closures have put
businesses on life support
jobless claims have surged in some
states more than 20% of the workforce
filed claims but in other states the
share is much lower an experts say the
numbers may still underestimate the
scope of people who are out of work
trying to access the benefit taking
states a while to process benefits as is
and to add in the new pandemic
unemployment assistance benefit the $600
and the 13 additional weeks here are
some of the obstacles holding states up
as they try to process the historic
number of unemployment claims challenge
number one the technology in some states
old technology has slowed down the
process in mid-march Connecticut
residents began to overload the state
Labor Department's website with claims
the portal could only handle about 8,000
benefit applications at a time once the
problem was resolved claims increased
sharply a spokesperson from
Connecticut's labor department said that
before the spike in claims the state was
already in the final stages of moving to
the cloud connecticut is far from the
only state with technology issues the
New York State Department of Labor had
to add computer servers to address the
flood of claims the department's
unemployment claims hotline received 8.2
million calls in the last week of March
compared with 50,000 in a typical week
the website recorded 3.4 million visits
compared with 350,000 normally only 16
states have upgraded off of their 1970s
COBOL mainframes entirely there are a
few states who have upgraded their
benefit system four states have upgraded
their benefit system three states have
upgraded their tax system but for the
most part states are still running on
pretty old technology challenge number 2
experience some states also lack
experience and setting up the systems
for the new unemployment funds according
to ever more some elements of the
pandemic unemployment assistance program
are based on the disaster program
disaster unemployment assistance has
been around since 1974 you know some
states are used to using the system
states that have a lot of natural
disasters have implemented disaster
unemployment
since before states like you know
Florida Louisiana they get hit with a
lot of hurricanes the Carolinas right
Texas but some states haven't had a lot
of natural disasters Arizona for example
hasn't had a natural disaster
declaration since 1983 and
coincidentally my colleague just found
out that they won't have their computers
up and running to process these benefits
for 18 weeks challenge number three
financial pressure some states like
Massachusetts are experiencing
additional financial pressures the new
federal unemployment programs make up to
39 weeks of unemployment insurance
available to previously uncovered groups
what gig workers the federal government
pays an additional $600 per week for
each successful claim through July 31st
but states are still on the hook for
standard unemployment payments those
payments range through two hundred
thirteen dollars a week in Mississippi
to about five hundred fifty dollars a
week in Massachusetts the average weekly
benefit amount in the United States is
about three hundred and seventy dollars
a week the average weekly wage in the
United States is around nine hundred and
seventy so that six hundred dollars
represents that gap to get workers to a
hundred percent the standard benefits
are paid by state unemployment trust
funds in some states have drawn down
their trust fund balances sharply
between February and April for example
Massachusetts spent more than half of
its unemployment trust fund balance in
that period a spokesman for the
Massachusetts Labor Department said the
state is committed to making sure
workers continue to receive the benefits
they deserve
several states have burned through their
cash and may seek additional loans from
the federal government to stay afloat
more than 20 states aren't positioned to
pay out enough and unemployment benefits
in the event of a recession according to
the journals analysis of Labor
Department data
[Music]